what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to the rumor roundup our
weekly series where we round up all the
rumors news and tidbits and all the
little things you've missed over the
course of the week and it's gonna be a
relatively short show this week not a
whole lot coming out but we do have a
pretty awesome kind of plot leak
basically
for spider-man no way home but before we
get into that
let's talk a little bit about the
playstation 5. specifically let's talk
about
ghosts of tsushima i loved that
game my god when that game first came
out i had no idea how good it was gonna
be if you've never played ghost of
tsushima
it's amazing it's basically about the
dawn of ninjas in in japan
but it is a beautifully done game i i
love the akira kurosawa moment like the
the whole
design where you can change the look of
the game to make it look like a kurosawa
film so it looks like you're playing
seven samurai it's amazing it's
ridiculously good but one of the things
that we're getting
for ghost ashima on the ps5 is we're
getting enhancements
and i love that they're doing that we're
getting some additions to photo mode and
that's cool because the photo mode was
really awesome you could make just some
ridiculously dramatic shots but what's
really awesome is we're getting
additions to
the main story in terms of extra content
and i love the developers doing that i
will say this the developers for ghost
of sushima have
worked their backsides off to really
provide quality content
for that game and one of the things that
pisses me off to no end
is when a game developer will release a
game for a console
and then like two or three years later
release that same game on the next
generation console
with no changes it just feels like
they're double dipping you know what i
mean just like taking a second bite at
the apple now i'm not asking for game
developers
to release a wholly new expansion for an
existing game that's
equal to the size of the game that i'm
playing i'm not asking for that after
all we don't all want to have to
download a 200 and something gigabyte
game
call of duty i'm just saying it's one of
those things where we would love to
to have it be worth our while if i'm
going to go out and buy you know spend
money on a playstation 5 and get
games for the playstation 5. while the
the catalog is fairly limited
if games from existing consoles on the
ps4 are going to be ported over
add a little bit to it and maybe like 10
hours of gameplay or something like that
something addition something equivalent
to like a normal expansion right just
make it worth my while that's all i'm
really asking for you know
just slave over that expansion and give
me the content i need
but i'm i'm a huge fan i'm really
excited i love ghost tsushima
and i'm really really excited to see
what the game is going to look like on
the ps5 because it was already gorgeous
on ps4 it could only look better from
there having said that
let's move into our first little bit of
information about spider-man no way home
i promise this is not the plot leak but
it is cool so the costume for spider-man
and spider-man no way home has been
leaked and when i say leaked i mean it's
actually been around for about three
years
but apparently it's just now getting out
there that people are aware of the fact
that it is the costume he's gonna have
in no way home so according to a tweet
from redacted which you know it's
literally the
twitter handle the redacted guy the
tweet that he sent out is that the new
look of the
of the costume was actually in the
spider-man far from home art book but
nobody really knew that was going to be
the costume in no way home so nobody
knew that it was going to be a leak
it was literally hiding in plain sight
but it looks cool it looks like it's a
combination
of the upgraded suit and the uh the iron
spider suit i'll be honest
i loved it when we got the iron spider
suit i love that the iron spider suit
was great right originally debuted in
civil war it was basically spider-man's
upgrade courtesy of iron man because he
sided with iron man during superhuman
registration
one of those you scratch my back i
scratch your kind of thing don't worry
that you dumped your identity to the
world peter parker and now
every criminal that you know is trying
to kill you and yours don't worry about
that
just enjoy the suit man but it is a cool
thing right the iron spider was just it
was a great concept
and i'm glad to see that with the marvel
cinematic universe it's not enough to
change the mythos of spider-man and it's
not enough to kind of update and to give
us new new content and new stories and
things like that focusing on on
different aspects of characters seeing
people like j jay jonah jameson come
back played by jk simmons i love that
they're updating the costume of
spider-man because i will say one of the
things about peter parker i do
understand the value of his costume
it's timeless it'll never get old it's
one of the most recognizable costumes in
the history of
really pop culture in general right you
could show that costume to like anybody
in the world right you could literally
go
to a to a primitive society in like the
rain forest
that's never had any measurable
encounter with modern society and show
them a picture of the spider-man costume
and they'll be like spider-man
spider-man they'll know exactly who
you're talking about right it's a wildly
iconic suit but at the same time
i like to see it change and adjust a
little bit i know there are those who
don't who are just like it needs to stay
the same but i love to see modifications
i love to see what kind of new stuff
they come up with
marvel's almost kind of treating it like
the iron man suits right where you kind
of get like a new version of the
spider-man suit every single time a new
movie comes out that features him i'm
not overly against it right the suit's
classic and at some point i'll probably
end up going back and focusing on the
classic suit but i'm kind of glad to see
they're changing things up a little bit
but having said that
i want to move away from the mcu for a
second kind of get back into gaming real
quick
and talk about ea's live event
electronic arts doing their live event
here's the thing for those of you guys
who haven't quite figured this out yet
e3 is the way things used to be not the
way things are
anymore and you can almost kind of set
your watch to it because it seems like
everybody's basically doing that now
right that you would have these great
huge events right e3
all that kind of stuff we would have a
lot of people who would kind of come
together and then
show off all this major stuff marvel
used to do it with d23
all the time and then now they kind of
have their own events essentially i'm
not 100 sure how i feel about that
there's a part of me that kind of misses
things like the spike video game awards
or the spike video game
events and seeing like all that
information dropped you're seeing e3
where all the game developers all show
up to to the e3 event and they all dump
their stuff
and it's a great big huge thing it's
like the olympics of video games i kind
of miss
that right i kind of miss that whole
thing what a lot of companies are doing
now is they're actually hosting their
own
separate events isolated from everybody
else and that kind of makes sense right
word of mouth marketing the internet the
whole nine yards i mean we basically
sell the products for them right so
there's a reason why
sony doesn't really have to go to e3 and
market all their video games and their
new consoles
if they say hey guys we got a ps5 coming
out and it sells out like that so
there's no real reason to do
a whole great big e3 thing but i do miss
it having said that electronic arts is
doing their live play event where they
basically have their own events showing
everything off
we're not going to see dragon h4 and
we're not going to see the new mass
effect
that sucks here's a big thing that i'm
kind of wondering when it comes to the
new mass effect game
i really hope they learned their lesson
from andromeda because
that game sucked no one out there right
now is making a case against that
there's no one who's going to be in the
uh
in the youtube comments saying actually
rob mass effect andromeda was fantastic
no one's coming to the rescue of that
game you understand what i'm saying
if mass effect andromeda was a world and
thanos showed up on it to get all the
infinity stones we would all just kind
of be like yeah thanos man you go ahead
and do your thing dude uh
yeah we we're good
[Laughter]
we don't need those guys that's that's
basically how people are treating it
right like it was an awful game it was
full of bugs it was terrible it was it
was it was bad i really hope that they
learned from andromeda because here's
the thing mass effect is a
beautiful series what made mass effect
so cool up until the end of mass effect
3 what made it so cool is that
all the games built on each other right
so your decisions would carry on into
the next game it was just like a giant
it was like reading a giant book right
it was just a giant cohesive story and
the fan base for for mass effect was
insane right it was it was
massive huge people loved mass effect
right they love the mass effect games
i'm really hoping mass effect
4 proves to be something that really
lives
up to the original mass effect myth of
so that really lives up to
basically everything that was mass
effects 1 2 and 3 until you got to the
ending of mass effect 3. i'm in the
crowd where i'm like yeah that was kind
of crappy the way they ended it but
nonetheless
i'm really hoping that it builds into
something great having said that i was
never a huge fan of dragon age so i'm
not really upset that we're not seeing
dragon age content here's my question
how many of you guys dug the doug the
dragon age series right how many of you
guys enjoy dragon age never a big fan of
it right never really got into it so
there is an announcement that is
supposedly coming during ea's live event
that's going to focus on star wars the
old republic you know what i'm just
going to go ahead and say it if it's not
star wars knights of the old republic 3
i don't care
i don't care ea is it star wars knight
to the old republic three
if the answer that question is no then
keep your announcement to yourself
whatever it is that you're gonna do just
go ahead and quietly release it and
slide it out there
if it's not star wars knight to the old
republic 3
and i'm not playing a video game that
tells me what happened to revan
i don't care i'm just going to say it
i'm sorry for all you guys who are
star wars the old republic fans but i
have been wanting a continuation
of coach ward 3 and not some the old
republic expansion that kind of answers
what happened with coach or three i mean
like a straight couture three game right
star wars knights of the old republic
three that's what i want that's what i
want to play
i would love it and please don't rush it
this time like you did with obsidian and
cold war 2.
that was awful he actually had to have
the fan base rebuild the game from
scratch
and release it as a patch on pc to make
a game that actually had
great playable content beyond what we
already got co-tour 2 was a great game
but it could be better getting into our
final bit of an announcement here our
final little tidbit here
as you guys know whenever it comes to a
lot of plot leaks things like that for
movies for the marvel cinematic universe
franchise a lot of those leaks don't
necessarily
come from industry insiders some of them
do but a lot of the leaks come from like
merchandise man then there's two big
leaks that have kind of come
out with spider-man no way home
regarding the merchandise sets the first
one actually shows mysterio and nick
fury and the indication here is that
mysterio and nick fury are going to be
in spider-man no way home there's a
couple ways to interpret this
you can interpret it like yeah i mean
they're in the movie in the same way
they're cast in the movie but the only
reason why you're going to see them in
the movie is because
one is nick fury and two they're going
to show flashbacks for mysterio so
that's how he's going to be in the movie
and that's how it's going to play out
with him
the other part of it and the existing
fan theory the one that i support is
that mysterio is not dead that
mysterious very much alive
that he faked his own death and created
that great big huge illusion and that's
basically it that mysterio really is
alive he was just that good at creating
illusions that he literally tricked
everybody
like the whole system into believing
that he was dead eating the ai of peter
parker
so i don't really know if that's going
to be the case or not if we're actually
going to see him but it would be cool if
we did
the next big leak that we kind of got
with that is basically a giant fight in
doctor strange's
sanctum sanctorum and i'm excited about
this because as you guys know
dr strange's saint of santorum is a
gateway to other places technically to
other sanctorums but
it could presumably be a gateway to
other dimensions and i'm excited to see
what possibly happens there too
well if the design of the lego set is to
be believed the big battle looks like it
might actually happen
at the end of the movie and that you've
got this great big huge arachnid
creature who's snatched people up and so
on and so forth
it's green in color which leads me to
believe something to do with the green
goblin
it could be this related to dr octopus
dr octopus has a long history of
creating those little mini arachnoid
type creatures
that go through and actually look at the
city of of new york
and find ways to defeat peter parker one
of the things that he actually did was
attach one of those to peter parker and
then copy his mind and that was a really
cool concept because
it allowed dr octopus to actually enter
the mind of peter parker and that's when
you ended up getting superior spider-man
which is one of the greatest comic book
spider-man runs in the history of marvel
comics i don't care what anybody says
but it looks like a great big huge brawl
so i feel like something like this
happening is only going to happen under
one of two circumstances either the
movie is going to
open with this great big huge conflict
or it'll happen in the first third
or it'll happen in the final third it'll
be like the last great big huge event
that goes on there so we don't really
get a whole lot of spoilers in terms of
like the various villains who were there
right it's not like it's showing
spider-man and doctor strange and wong
all facing off against like chameleon
and venom
and like morbius and doctor octopus the
green goblin
i think if that happened marvel would be
pissed right they'd be mad to say oh
like
why did you release this you literally
just spoiled the plot of a whole movie
which we already kind of figured anyway
but
nonetheless you know it's one of those
things right it's it's a cool a cool
little thing but it looks like we're
getting a great big huge battle
with what looked like the previously
created forces of dr octopus
somebody like like green goblin or what
have you regardless these little tidbits
keep coming out
all the time and i got to be honest man
they're doing a great job of building
the hype for spider-man no way home i am
so
excited for this movie to come out i am
so looking forward to it
as much as i hate the winter winter
can't come fast enough
with that being said guys thank you all
for watching leave some comments down
below let us know if there was some news
that we missed from last week
and we will catch you all later peace